i'm gonna be the person who helps me
so then i can start helping other people
[Music]
hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
with ibb and hustling what's going down
guys now listen if you've ever wanted to
get into rent to rent start a renter in
portfolio or get into property with very
little money these guys have done it
financially free yeah financially free
in just a matter of months this is i'm
going to be asking you so many detailed
questions because i want you to be able
to do the same thing too let's go well
thank you so much for coming down to my
house guys between the two of you you've
gone from one property deal two to three
to four your full-time property
you've now got to the point where you
don't need to work anymore um
talk to me a little bit about your
backstories when did you get into
property how did it all start and we're
gonna get some real nuggets today so we
went to neck a birmingham event in
um in birmingham to see grant cardone
and gary vee so we were we were just
like okay we need to go there and i was
just going to him like there's this
event because we never go to any events
before
so i said we need to go there grant
cardone's there and he's like no it's a
scam
yeah he's like no like we shouldn't go
to stuff like that because it was like
300 pounds at the time that's a lot for
us
so we i just dragged them and we went
and it was an event called un unlock
your potential
and i feel like that's where everything
started the world opened yeah what did
you think of that event did you totally
change your mind or we don't get to go
100 so we fell in love with grants after
it we started watching those of grant
cardone videos replacing netflix or just
his videos yeah i got to a point where
it's like it's good but it's not really
relatable yeah so we googled uk version
of grant cardone and you came out yeah
we started watching your videos we was
like
binge watching your videos yeah what
year was this 2019 end of 2019. we
actually came to a crash course
in end of 2019 i was reluctant to go i
was like no let's not go it's in london
we haven't got time we've got them we
want to manage the kid and he was like
no we're going we went down there we
almost signed up we still like we had
that resistance he wasn't sure
we just kept thinking it's like too good
to be true yeah and all the energy and
stuff so we come to three crash courses
wow
yeah because we like it we just love the
energy that we get from the events from
you we're still like oh we do still hold
the poor mentality we still hold them as
[ __ ] what was that mentality that was
making you think is too good to be true
you know
this isn't real what where did that come
from
i think him just telling ourselves we
haven't got the money when realistically
we did if we really wanted it right
because it because it's not about
whether you've got the money or not it's
about whether you've got the deals or
not because if you've got the deals the
money will come exactly yeah so you were
thinking i haven't got the money so
what's the point in looking for the
deals
mine was just
just because i've never had like rich
family
so i just thought you have to work hard
and get make money you can't just make
money that easily because if it is you
have to pay something back
one way or another yeah i mean i'm there
talking about packaging and selling
deals controlling properties no money
down
you it would just sound a bit like whoa
really yeah yeah we i mean we tried it
ourselves after it um but we didn't
really have that kind of
push and these basic things that we
didn't know the answer to and so that
just kind of made us step back even
further and what we did at the time
um we secured the lease option off the
back of it wow um we ended up backing
out of it just because we couldn't do
sister accommodation on the plan b was
just use it as a single let
but we were just still unsure about it
and we ended up backing away from it so
you did a bit of free training
you kind of
success or property was almost at your
fingertips and you felt like oh it was
close um hadn't invested into any
training um or paid for any proper
education but i've done a bit of the
free stuff i've watched a lot of the
youtube videos what were you working on
at the time
so i was working full
in a sports supplement company a new
full-time mum full-time one-year-old and
two-year-old wow busy yeah and and how
did you guys meet
i met in the gym we met in the gym like
eight years ago
well i'm feeling very fat next to you
both
but um so congrats on the success from
the gym in fact i remember i remember at
one of the uh meetings that we had like
about about a year ago
and you know you were kind of like your
energy was great really excited ready to
roll
i'm sure thousands of people can relate
to where you were at that point been on
a few free courses watched loads of
videos on the brink
in shape happy successful good energy
but there was just something that wasn't
quite clicked actually you said to both
of us you said to it you said you're
going to be really successful i can see
your future and you said to me just look
at me wins
you need to read your theory stop bro
ouch
and i was like what no and then the
second video and then the second time
what did he say to you he said to him
like don't be a [ __ ]
and i i fear like i was reflecting on it
at night i was like does he think he is
like saying that and then i reflect on i
was like you know he's right like why am
i getting defensive towards this quite
an offensive thing to say though let's
say you're gonna be really successful
you though you changed your game both
loved one it's a tough love and i don't
think you're not gonna say that to
everyone yeah but do you feel like you
could it benefits interest as well
because when i'm really hard on people
if i say to a dude you know you need to
up your game you're being a [ __ ] i'll
only say that to someone that i know can
handle it that's what you said
afterwards as well right because you you
knew and then you
like liked that or something you told me
you know you want someone to call you
that and like push you down it's about
being
someone being straight with you isn't it
because most people will pat you on the
back and say oh yeah you're great well
actually you need to be told the truth
and i won't say to someone you're being
a [ __ ]
unless i because some people have
crushed them
whereas i knew that it be actually he
had a lot of potential smart good energy
had a lot of greatness but he was
holding himself back and he needed
someone to shake him give him a punch in
the mouth yeah
come on you know which is what happened
so when did you really start taking
property serious and when did you guys
say we're gonna go all in forget our
limiting beliefs we're gonna get around
good people we start we got to rent a
rent before coming on to the dsm yes and
but we had it for months wasn't really
doing anything wasn't really pushing
ourselves anymore and then in november i
came to the dsm
and the energy was amazing laying a lot
of new things and that's when he was on
stage during the role play yes um
and i think again i don't think he would
have done that to a lot of people oh i
had complaints about that
well i think that was well i'm happy for
it i'm happy you've done it that was a
big turning point for me so just for
anyone that was wondering what happened
he come to did the fe and i was in the
hotel room looking after the kids like
five minutes away and i was on stage was
doing role play um
sales right yeah sales role play and he
just looked and i had a black badge on
he's like you're not doing the academy
and i was like no and he's like okay why
not i said you want to be honest on
stage he's like yeah go for it i just
said why i didn't want to join the
academy i felt like
i thought i think i've got the knowledge
on a lot of stuff already and i just
want to focus on rent to rent i don't
want to bombard me minded all of their
concepts and strategies and he's like
okay okay
let's try a little role play then i'm
going to sell you the academy trying to
try it so in front of 150 200 people
were on stage and you're selling me the
academy but in like role play mode role
play mall
you're asking me questions and i'm
trying to give her back a little bit and
it got to a point where you just said no
you've got money you've got you've got
you've got you've established you've got
enough for the academy and crypto you
could afford it yeah my my point there
was okay
in my mind i was thinking
the money for the academy what's my
return on investments if i keep it in
crypto best case scenario let's say 10
x's
i'm still going to be in the same
position
working i haven't got enough time but
have i invested into skills yeah and
into
expanding and trying to make uh give
myself more free time
i'm going to be in a completely
different situation
and you said to me yeah 200 return on
investment's easy i said i want more
than that and you went
waste case scenario it's 100 retain on
investment
and i was like i want to get more time
and the potential to grow a lot further
so for me was 100 worth it and i was
just like you know what [ __ ] it let's
let's do it and since then it's just
pushed us so much it literally has
because you can you can be online you
watch all those videos but it's not what
you need and you're always unsure is
this the right information but after
joining the academy i'm so grateful like
that happened on stage because if it
didn't we'll just still be coming to you
know crash courses and just going safe
going safe
and that was just like we got the right
people around us and there's nothing
going to stop us now and you've achieved
so much in the last um sort of three or
four months you know you've got now
multiple rent service accommodation
properties you've still got the initial
rent that you had you've packaged and
sold deals you're now looking to grow on
scale up to do bigger deals development
joint ventures um financially free yeah
so congratulations congratulations um
but i really just wanted to kind of pick
your brain in this interview about 2022
okay
you've secured a lot of rent to rents
how do you how do you find good deals
how do you work out where how do you
know if it's a good deal or a bad deal
what are the exact steps for someone
watching this now you've invested a lot
in yourself in your education if you
have to summarize and condense
everything that you've learned
what are you going to do how do you
implement and get
um so
when you're starting
what we've done was just have a plan
literally write it on what do i want to
do this year what do i want to achieve
and literally break it down
and then from then on what we do is okay
how can we add value to anyone even to
the cleaners even to the estate agent so
we'll go and speak to estate agents like
we're building a relationship i don't
care if i go to the viewing and we don't
take on the property we just go in to
get value add value how can i help here
before i get money and that's the type
of approach that we had with everyone
what can we do to that person before i
get my own
so what you're saying is rather than
thinking i need to get a deal i need to
make money it's about thinking actually
how
rather than thinking from my perspective
i need a deal i need money
who's going to give me a deal right how
can i help them how can i add to them
because i think it's same with written
tournaments a lot of people think i want
a route around it's like no no let's
think about what service this is
who needs this service
and instead you're almost thinking about
how how as a business you can add value
to others and then as a result you'll
get what you want that's really helpful
you've done that really well actually
what i am started doing is ringing
landlords and say look i see you've got
a room an empty room spare room i'll
find the tenant for you
give me two weeks rent but i'll find it
for you and you would go in there take
better pictures dress the room marked it
a lot better and you you'd be finding
all the landlords tenants because yeah i
would keep them adverts online and when
people start messaging us about all
these good rooms it acted like a funnel
to our own rental rent as well wow
wow because that was like the turning
point where
oh my god i can actually charge a
landlord two weeks rent just by finding
a tenant and 200 pound
it's like i just thought like whoa
that's a lot of money at the time and
it's like we can be creative
we can provide value and get paid for it
because
dressing the room wasn't you know just
go to a shop get dressed and take a nice
picture and we'll rent it out easily um
interesting
it even let us know
based in liverpool and known other
people in their own areas you have
assumptions about bad areas who would
never invest there but it lends us to um
golf facts rather than assumptions
because some of these areas where he was
founded tenants he was actually a really
good demand there interesting i think as
well what i found is when you uh are
working in an area where you know
sometimes it can be hinderance because
like i grew up in warsaw
and i used to think oh warsaw's horrible
warsaw's terrible and i started
investing in birmingham and then a few
people some of my friends oh i'm looking
at jenny morsel and i just thought oh
horrible but actually i was judging it
because
it's got a bit of a bad and i think
actually if you just look at the numbers
it's not really that horrible there's
some parts that are really horrible but
actually i was almost just throwing it
all out because i'm like oh no not
warsaw um but yeah really important that
the assumptions you've got to look at
the actual facts how do you go about
finding your patch how do you find your
area because that's something that
people get really really confused and
lost in yeah so i think um you've got to
figure out what you want to go for
service accommodation or hmo
personally i suggest so a lot of people
to start off with hmos that's what you
did yeah because what you can do when
you're on the phone as well you can be
like hi i'm looking at five bed
house uh blah blah blah and then while
you're on the phone you say actually
you've got any studios or one beds while
i'm here i might be able to take it off
your hands that's not that much of a big
deal
so you can kind of target both at the
same time yeah so figure out what you
want to do for hmos you've got to find
out the supply and demand within all the
postcodes of the air of the city
to find out which areas are popping
which ones are you going to get tenants
really fast
um you could probably get a hmo in any
part of your city
if you market it right but if you just
go down deeper and find out which
specific area is going to pop even
better
then you can easily get a you can easily
fill it and for us that that was really
powerful because
we still had that inclination of is it
going to work isn't it and then when
we've got all this data saying actually
there's um there's a load of hmos
already exist in there yeah let's target
that hmo and we can easily fill the
rooms talk to me about your first rent
to hmo talk to me about that what how
did you find that and what were the
figures so it was a nine bed hmo nine
beds
licensed in liverpool okay so he's
already ready um the guy the landlord
had um rent a rent pacing managing it so
he actually gave it to a company to
manage it but that company wasn't doing
well so the landlord gave it to him with
i think six tenants yeah and then he was
struggling so but this was during
pandemic and he was just struggling
really bad and he said
he just he just had to give it back to
the landlord wow with two tenants and he
was there he was building that
relationship with the landlord and we
just kind of like
you know adding value to him and then he
was we just kind of took it on from him
yeah just um you actually started
finding tenants for that landlord
oh yeah that's what i was doing so i was
finding tenants for this landlord and
then he had loads of these properties
and
because we was just doing you know
finding landlords and he knew what kind
of things we were doing he just said she
want to take this on yeah so that
property then if it sucked for the
previous person doing a rent to rent
why does it work for you so the previous
person he didn't live in liverpool
didn't live anywhere near liverpool and
he had a letting agent manage him for
him so 40 he thought it'd be passive
income yeah be the middleman but renter
enters some passive income it's only
passive for the landlord
that's so i'm so glad you said that
because i often see people even like
buying rent to rents off people and they
just think oh i'll pay you three grand
and you can find me a rent to rent and
i'll just sit back and do rent to rent
is a business exactly yeah it's like
it's like why is it that a restaurant
might not work and then someone comes
over and it gets new management and
suddenly it makes money because now it's
under new management it's being managed
properly in the same way rent to rents
it's not sometimes a case of is that a
good deal or is it a bad deal it's are
you a good entrepreneur or are you a bad
entrepreneur and that's how a lot of
people think and how we used to think as
well i just wanted passive income i
don't want to do no work because i was
just with that poor mindset but now
after getting these properties i'm like
i love working like i want to manage
more properties it's like i love it yeah
and the the landlord who owns it you
know we say we always think of tired
landlord a
beating off property but this guy killed
him he's like a property millionaire
he's trying to expand his business by
going to the developments so he he can't
manage that he can't be bothered he'd
rather make 800 quid a month and have
zero
but have to go out a few times a month
and do bits and bobs and there's letting
agents keep letting them down yeah it's
same brilliant so so pro figures how
much do you pay him per month
1700
and then you then rent the whole thing
what does what's the gross turnover of
the property
uh gross turnover is i don't know but
it's one thousand profits in one three
four fifty at
the profit a month it was actually lower
it was like seven seven hundred and
fifty but we've like figured ways out
how to push that profit up even further
yeah
during the pandemic and obviously we
struggled the first couple of months to
find tenants and that's where i had to
just try all different things to figure
out what he created what did you do how
did you push how did you push it up i've
dressed the rooms so his pictures would
just um take a you know just mattress
so i went and dressed the room and it's
so cheap go to range get nice pillows
bedding but the tennis keep that as well
yeah we we just give that to the tenants
but i know some people you know just
take it back after sign the contract but
we just add value to the tenants and we
also give them welcome pack so we give
them you know shampoos toiletries fruits
healthy landlords and so we do stuff
like that and
also let's start on airbnb we also list
on airbnb
we contact um
go on facebook market
so we literally put leaflets everywhere
as well
with the airbnb we'll have a room we'll
list on airbnb with a minimum stay of 60
days 90 days
and what usually happens is we'll get
international students
or people moving from different like for
example we've got one guy in there from
uzbekistan
coming over to liverpool to work in a
hospital but he doesn't really know
about a spare room he's familiar with
airbnb so for him it's just a lot easier
yeah and we charge him everyone else in
the house pays 350 a room he pays 500 to
550 a room from airbnb
so we're getting a good tenant but also
to pay more as well we also
contact people international people
because it's hard for them to come to
new countries settle down so we help
with that so we give them because they
need the address for the visa so we'll
go okay sign pay your deposit this is
the contract this is what you need to
you know show your visa people and what
we just helped them like this is the
cheap taxis we literally just hold you
know the experience of coming to
the uk we help with that so it's kind of
like
you're very you're very proactive with
your marketing then
rather than just sitting back and
thinking oh just let a letting agent do
it you're literally
pushing the rents up all over it which
is why you make a grand a month profit
now whereas the previous guy wasn't
making any money
and
we also increased the rent every time
someone leaves
not when the tenants are in but when
someone leaves by 5 or 10 pounds
yeah what makes sense everything goes up
so that's your first property your
serviced accommodation properties
what is rent to service accommodation
and why would a landlord not just do it
themselves so basically rent-a-service
accommodation is where you take a whole
property
and you just let out on short-term stays
um for the landlord
they want a guaranteed rent do you want
to fix rent instead of having someone in
all the time they could be losing money
with letting agents paying their
management fee
tenant finding fees every time someone
boots out there's void periods they have
to kind of do like refurbishment every
time someone moves out
so if they get someone in there doing
rent or rent and taking it all on it
takes off all a hassle and they've got a
fixed rent coming in each month they can
walk away basically like the advantage
of commercial property exactly yeah
where the tenant is responsible for
everything and you become not the tenant
but you become the point of contact for
the landlord do everything but then you
then list it on airbnb and booking.com
and you know how to run that business
for the landlord as well we don't have
any tenants rights so it gives him that
extra security if we're not paying rent
or anything like that
goes out and the guests that have turned
us either so effectively there's no
tenants in all of this yeah exactly
which is brilliant and it's kept to a
much higher standard as well and i like
i like how you like you know agree you
agree with us and saying this is what
you do but all of this information we've
got to offer you
yeah but you know what though you've got
it off mate but then you've lived it and
now you're sharing it back from
experience
so it's it's it's it's incredible how do
you how do you know how do you do your
research before you take on a service to
accommodation rent to rent and how do
you know if it's gonna be profitable or
not and how accurate are your
projections
you've done most of the research with
service accommodations wasn't it you
just follow notes yeah samuels uh
blueprints on your online course
every every week
you whatever you say i just do it
because i believe in you like 100 i'm
just like yeah i don't need to be like
smart and try and like use my brain i'm
just going to copy what he's i'm just
going to do yeah i'm just going to copy
and paste what he says every time you
say go to receptionist go speak to them
i i went and done it in a hotel yeah in
a hotel
i even went to i even went to a hotel
room dead confidence and i was like yeah
i want to speak to someone here because
i want to take on some of these rooms
myself and my company and they're like
okay yeah come back tomorrow and i was
like we just come out like what we what
did we just do is like actually talk me
through what happened when you went to
the hotel and asked about their
occupancy rights because that is i don't
think most people actually do that i
told them not to go
don't go
but firstly so people can understand why
did you do it
so i went in there um because this was
after we done we we've seen a really
luxurious apartment to take on for an
essay and we was just like you know
let's go to a rich cafe you know we want
to manifest and let's go to a rich cafe
and there was a
hotel next door and we're like come
let's go speak to them see if we can
take on some of the rooms from them and
you was going like what like no we can't
do that and i was like no we could do
that like samuel told me you'll talk
so it's fine i'll go in
but they were just receptionists and
they said like come back speak to my
manager but they were like open to it
wow yeah that's incredible sometimes i
feel like walking in is more powerful
than over the phone because you've got
that rapport that connection
um so how do you how what's the most the
best way that you found success because
i know there's like many different ways
of getting um rent-to-service
accommodations where do you find them
where are they coming from um so for us
it's been through an agent
um building a rapport with someone and i
think just realizing that the letting
agents they're just human beings so what
do you say when you call the lining
agent i'm the letting agent hello best
of weaves how can i help are you okay i
see there's an apartment available on
church road um could the book of you and
please sure absolutely what's your uh
what what's your
situation also i have an accommodation
business somewhere and a house working
professionals and
international students have he's only
got that one property ideally i need
about five in that area oh wow um yeah
we've got this one at the moment but if
anything else comes up i can let you
know would you like to book a viewing
okay perfect can we do tuesday or
wednesday
oh wow um
wednesday yeah wednesday works we'll do
the viewing on wednesday around 12-ish
if you do get any more um properties pop
up can we just book them in before 12 or
after 12. what did you say your
situation was
you provide housing for people what
what's the uh what's the name of your
company how does it work so my company
is your property investment and we house
international students and sometimes
you'll have working professionals as
well okay i'd have to check with the
landlord to see if he'd be open to doing
that sort of
so who would be living in the property
so international students as i said
before um we do have working
professionals coming in so did you say
you'd have to check with the landlord is
this something that you i've done before
um yeah no i just have to uh you know i
think um you know have to speak to the
landlord just to see whether he'd be
okay with that sort of arrangement but
um yeah i mean we can pencil in the
viewing for wednesday at 12 and um i'll
drop you an email over and i'll it never
any problems beforehand okay what was
your name again my name's samuel pfx
samuel can't wait to see you all right
see you soon bye
cool respect hi um can i add my pot so
what i do is i tell them um i work with
these big companies i don't want to say
the names just in case
it's big companies in liverpool i i've
i've went which is true right yeah i've
caught i've contacted them and said look
we provide accommodations and they've
said yeah sure they said yeah right
right so then i'll speak to state agents
and say i work with this this companies
and we provide accommodation to their
staff or anyone who's yeah that's
brilliant and let me see your question
why do so many latin agents hate
rental rents i think one they just i
found that a lot of the agents have been
told no it's evil
we have our own properties they're
trying to get one over on us right and
then some yeah these some just think
it's subletting they don't understand it
and some have had bad experiences as
well right i think with our script as
well it's not just everyone says watch
your script watch your script we just
have facts and then we just flow with
the conversation and you've got your
style i've got my style we just do it as
like okay if we actually set this
business up how would we go about it
without your teachings or
whatever like online teachings so we
just try and change a little bit stand
out a little bit you don't stamp on it
yeah don't just say the same script as
everyone because everyone's ringing judy
corporal let you do corporate yeah but
we just want to say this is the business
that we created this is our model how
can you help us how can we help you yeah
and i think just back to the ad and
value part which is very important we
used to ring up like it's who can we do
a rental rent well actually we're
providing a really good service yeah a
lot of less agents and property
management a lot of them are useless so
we're going in we're providing a really
good service and even if they're good
even if they're a good leading agency
you know i mean i used to run a letting
agent say i've also worked in an estate
agency countrywide and even if they're a
good letting agent it their landlord
that they're they're representing wants
rent
their landlord's on empty property and
wants rent if you're coming along and
saying we want to rent your property
on a contract
with extra bonuses because it is also a
numbers game right yeah if if an agent
says or a landlord says no don't worry
that then you just you don't have to
check it personal some people will ring
up trying to i mean you actually want me
over but but but some people will ring
up a landlord or an agent and the agent
will shut them down or say no don't deal
with that don't do comedy let's can't do
that and then the entrepreneur on the
phone will feel rejected hurt but
they're not rejecting you they're
rejecting your
business concept they're rejecting the
idea they're not rejecting what i found
useful as well it's like the the art of
sales and conversation where when you're
talking to them don't expect and don't
get sucked up onto their story for
example even if you're ringing up for a
uh
you want to buy a could be a rundown
property it could be a renter rent
anything when you ask them straight away
you might say no because they don't
understand it yeah so whatever they say
just open up that conversation and it
opens up a lot more doors as well so
profit-wise what kind of profit would
you be expecting to make or what would
you say is average for your properties
with your service departments um well
you said 50 break even at 50 percent
right what does that mean break even at
50 okay so 50
whenever guests come in for one month at
50 occupancy so guests only come in for
15 days and then you should cover your
costs in other words if you have 50
occupancy rate which is terrible because
average is 83
if you have 50
you should not be losing money you
should be breaking even anything above
50
is profit so okay
but our deals
we don't just break even at 50 percent
we make profit on that wow
so 55 on one we're making 1800. 1800 on
one yeah and on the other one it's 20
1200. it's four five oh my goodness i
know a lot of people do apartments but
you can't do essay the whole house as
well did you think it was too good to be
true before you signed the contract yeah
i still think you even think that now
but you know the moon's coming in yeah
we was at your event the other day and
we were just sitting and then my phone
like a notification come up and it says
three nights
three nights 4 50. someone paid already
and i just like wow i'm just making
money while sitting here things that we
manifested or the things that i wanted
it's coming true like even on being on
winners on wednesday it was like
unwritten goal
but we just coming on here so soon it's
like surreal
i think um one important thing i'd like
to share as well that's helped us a lot
and kind of visualize what's a good deal
and what's not a good deal is something
called what we call a 3ms so you need to
work out whenever you go to any renter
and deal what's the maximum amount of
capital that you want to put down
so for us it was five thousand we don't
wanna put more than five thousand into a
deal so for the uh furniture first one's
rent deposits decorations we don't wanna
put more than 5k yeah so the next one is
the minimum amount of profits what's the
minimum amount of profit you're willing
to make on a deal so for us it's 500 if
it's below 500 we don't want to touch it
and the last one is the months how many
months do you get your money back so we
want to get our money back under six
months yeah so using these three things
if the deal doesn't stack up straight
away maybe it's
not making it we're not getting our
money back until 10 months but like okay
well how do we figure out how to reduce
our initial capital maybe we'd get a
grace period maybe reduce the rents
maybe we're being too conservative maybe
we need to um get the finish out on a
lease like what can we do and all of
this we figured out a strategy for to
make the property work and then we use
that and put that into the offer
if that makes sense yeah that's awesome
like that's how you when i said have a
plan and then break it down yeah yeah
that's how it gives you a lot of clarity
yeah with anything not just to say
because a lot of people look at deals
and go oh it doesn't work well how can
we make it work how can we increase the
rent how can we reduce the monthly costs
and that that it all comes together in
the offer that we send to there
guys um obviously part of the academy
which is amazing but you've been such an
asset to the academy you know you give
so much in fact you know within your
whole business the way you are with your
landlords and tenants and agents you're
always thinking what can i give and um
you know i know you've um
you've set up a group where you're
helping moms in property on social media
which is just amazing and ibby i know
you dream one day you've got a fire to
be to be to be a trainer and to be to be
a speaker and to write books and to help
people and pull people up which which i
understand because that's that's what i
do where does that come from and and
where does that passion and desire to to
want to sort of help others bring others
into the community and the amount of
people that you've brought into the
academy as well like you're bringing
you're almost like um a financial
evangelist you know so where does that
come from and what what that that
passion and desire so my one my
experiences when i had the kids we both
planned our kids but i just thought i
was going to be really good mum like i
look after them really well but i really
struggled and i just couldn't get out
the house i was just in my bed and i
just went through like really low stage
because
it's like lucky right to have a kid and
it's like almost like you shouldn't
struggle and i try to do things myself
as well you know do everything by myself
and still try and do property on the
side so i wasn't getting no help and
because i just thought it's my
responsibility i have to do this but i
was just struggling and struggling and i
know a lot of mums go through this as
well like they just can't like i
couldn't cook and i was just
breastfeeding my kids but everyone was
saying oh you're so good breastfeeding
but
i was just doing that because i there
was i just felt lazy procrastinating but
it was to do with my mental health
but once you fix your mental health not
fix once you
help yourself
and
work on your mental health then
everything started changing like i don't
get that now i wake up
excited
and that's what i want to help other
parents because i know what they go
through and i know that thing where you
know you should socialize and just
cancel push everyone out and
literally mine i was like oh my god
property actually helped me get out of
this
how did property help you how did it
help you because i was really struggling
financially because i just felt like
i was
stuck and i just needed to you know i
was just gonna go crazy like i just
couldn't be a stay-at-home mom i know
like people love that but to me i just
couldn't there was something in me i
just had to leave this house but i
couldn't leave the house
so i
just one day i just said you know what
i'm waiting for someone to come and help
me i'm waiting for
you know eb to make money and to get
become rich and i just said to myself do
you know what i'm going to be that
person i'm going to be that rich person
i'm going to be the person who helps me
so then i can start helping other people
and it's
and then telling myself i deserve this
as well because i kept going you know
it's i don't know some reason i just
thought
i don't deserve it because compared to
my relatives or someone else you know
like there's in poor countries they're
doing
worse than me so i just said like you
know
this i shouldn't deserve this but then i
started going no do you know what i
actually went through so many things and
yeah wow that's powerful you realize
that you're the person that you've been
waiting for yeah
and i didn't have no friends i
yeah i didn't really have any close
friends like loyal friends and i just
said you know what i'm just not going to
wait for them i'm just going to be that
friend to myself and
property i've i've met so many amazing
people
and
like it's making me money it's making me
friends it's you know it's
i've got different lifestyle now
yeah that's amazing it's just realizing
that money and property is a tool and
that's like it just helps deserve
everything you've you know you've
achieved you've seen i deserve it and
the more things start coming and then
the more i help people
like in the academy group i used to
i i'll sometimes go oh
guys come on i'm sending positive
affirmation let's see you get that keys
let's see you sign the contract tomorrow
and i didn't realize i was doing that
and then i'd look back and like all the
things that i send out is coming back to
me as well
so karma
karma yeah it really is i think for me
um
anyone who knows me i'm always kind of
just genuinely trying to help people
whether it's on a small scale a big
scale i've just got that thing giving me
that just i just like helping people
and i found as i'm doing it more
it's it creates a positive peer pressure
i'm helping everyone else build up and
advance their property journey and then
when i see these people doing well i'm
like oh [ __ ] i need to i need to step up
i need to raise my thermostat yeah and i
need to open myself yeah and so it's i
think people you know me i'm just i just
like to help and i'm just genuine like
that but the benefits of that is it
literally creates a really positive and
i think as well when you when you push
other people up i mean in property it's
not like someone else's success isn't
your downfall actually the more your
people around you succeed the more you
succeed as well so everyone wins
together do you really surprise the
amount of people who have that mindset
where they don't help with the people
and keep other people down but the more
people you bring up yeah can i elevate
yourself as well absolutely well i'm
really excited i know you've also been
doing a lot of other stuff you've got
some deals going on in the background
you've been packaging and selling deals
how many deals have you got four deals
now yeah four and a half yeah and on
average
what kind of fee are you charging three
grand some of them a little bit less
some of them a little bit more but we've
been called people as well where they
bring us deals and then we connect them
to the investor so you've been selling
you've been doing ideal selling you've
been doing rent to hmos went to service
accommodation what's next for eb and
hustling over the next 12 months okay so
i've created a plan
and i just said um this year we're going
to have 12 essays
and
what he wants hmos but i want 12 essays
12 essays and 11 000 profit a month
because the 1000 i want to spend on fun
things um
yeah amazing beyond ours as well that
we're gonna do oh yeah so we gonna do
brrs as well so one or two bros this
year so we've worked on them so we're so
deal source and we're finding deals for
the people but what we're doing is we're
looking for deals for ourselves and we
didn't realize how many people
have got money anyone invested in us and
do a joint venture so uh which is local
we have we have loads of investors now
yeah being active on social media we
have investors asking us have you got
deals and we're like um no so we need to
get more deals incredible well guys huge
huge respect and it's been a real
pleasure working with you over the last
few months and um i'm really excited to
the next stages and thank you for such a
valuable interview as well with so many
golden nuggets i appreciate it guys i
hope you've enjoyed the interview with
ibi and hustling what a packed gem
filled interview with so many golden
nuggets if you enjoyed it let me know in
the comments below drop a comment don't
forget to subscribe to the channel if
you want to connect to ibby and hustling
i'm going to leave their details and
website in the description as well you
can subscribe to the channel right up
over here and if you want to come down
to the property investors crash course
then don't forget to get booked on free
tickets right here and i'll see you guys
next time
[Music]
you